that we're here with christopher Judge
at collector mania hello it's uh it's
really great to be here no yeah thank
you for having me we're delighted to
have you here I mean one of the shows
you've been in which has been searching
for nauman and people are still queuing
up like mad here to have your autograph
signing to talk to you Stargate why do
you think it was such a phenomena um you
know I think we first of all came along
at the right time there was a shortage
of sci-fi shows at that time and you
know I think I think the thing that that
made it relatable was the interaction
between the characters uh you know we
got along off-screen and I think it
really came across on the screen and we
just never really took ourselves that
seriously you know we understood that we
were there to make entertainment and wow
we always wanted to have fun and I think
that fun really kind of kind of came
across in the screen how much fun we
were actually having rainy just come
across on the screen what do you think
this isn't one of the big appeals about
stargates people what really caught
their imagination about this area well i
think it's it's kind of what what the
universal of science fiction is the
wonderment of it all day and the
exploration of it you know other worlds
other other people input and and a lot
of the shows was an allegory for it what
kind of what's going on in the world and
what's what's I file allows you to do is
talk about issues without making it
preachy and without without hitting
people over the head with it you know so
i think was just a wonderful vehicle to
be able to do that mean for yourself
Chris what do you enjoy about that
particular genre
for me it was always just how much how
much fun we had on set you know it's
never a job when you when you look
forward to going somewhere you know it's
it was never I mean not that we didn't
have long days and not that it wasn't
hard work but it just it never seemed
like work you know I mean we just always
laughed you know now I'm sure love
you've been asking you what it's like
working with people i reckon around
today but for the people you haven't
been able to make it here to collect
romania tell them at home what it was
like working with Rick and Amanda I
can't say that now we want to know you
know one of the things that especially
people didn't know about rick is just
what a big kid he is and you know he
really set the tone for the show I mean
you know he's a prankster he's a
jokester just a tremendous sense of
humor and a much the chagrin of some of
our producers and directors if there was
a joke to be told or a laughs to be had
that the filming was secondary and I and
a lot of that came from Rick on down you
know and it was just it was a wonderful
I mean who's is everyone that we worked
was wonderful the guest stars when they
came were wonderful it was just a very
you know I've done a lot of stuff and we
were a very unusual set um
in just that fun was always job one you
know I mean so it was just a great
experience it's great that it comes
across like that on the screen it was so
I want to know a bit more about some of
those Frank's now you mentioned Rick and
his joke playing well I think one of the
things that anyone will tell you that we
had one of the stinkiest sets in hot or
are ya our love of a good what good
farts was legendary and and encouraged
uh-huh so what we till could made of
this see I i I'm jet lag and punchy
right now so I know we did what I mean
just uh you know that that was part of
the fun of it like just all the
practical jokes and stuff we play on
each other and uh oh and how we change
our diets to me I thought even gonna go
crazy for a little bit
I'm intrigued now finished our senses oh
no I get I can't I said too much Oh be
revealed in a future date exactly
exactly I want to think everyone to talk
about because we talk is a great
character I wanted to ask you about
those shirts that cut those costumes on
that show did you enjoy wearing those I
did and Christina Macquarie really went
when she would bring like she's a little
hesitant at first to bring like all the
wild shirts and stuff and then when she
saw that i would literally where
everything that that she would bring it
just got wilder and what I think was
really her goal to find something that I
wouldn't wear and it just never happened
what was your favorite show you there is
this monstrosity of this red and kind of
yellowish shirt that was supposed to be
like the Sun or flames or something like
that it was truly the ugliest shirt that
I've ever seen I think that was one of
my great joys that sure talking about
your favorite moments on the show which
are you kind of favorite scenes or
memory some filming offset Navy um I
think that my favorite episode this
shoot was probably the 200 just because
it was such a we got to do all these
skits and and uh kind of Lampoon other
shows i guess if you are not even i'm
from paid tribute to to a bunch of other
shows and we had people like come to set
like who real from wardrober
construction or whatever that had never
been on set in 10 years they all came
that week and it was it was an
incredibly difficult episode to do not
not from an actor standpoint but from a
production standpoint because we
generally did four or five different
kind of little mini shows within that
show and they still had the same amount
of time to prep for it as they do for it
as a different any other show and
everyone did it with a smile
and happy and laughing and joking and it
was just a wonderful wonderful week and
I think my favorite show my favorite
episode to watch was probably heroes
because I think that was the episode
that really encompassed everything from
the show it was it was funny but it was
it was touching and you know dozen
episode of dr. Frasier died in and it
was it was heartwarming and and it was
just it's just one my my favorite
episodes to watch it's rare isn't it for
show to get all of those tones which
have quite different rights and you know
it it actually became a two-parter just
because there was so much in it um and
you know to the writers credit they
really just turned Terrell loose and I
mean she just she just tore it up and
I'm it's just one my favorite
performances now I want to know everyone
wants to know what you're up to at the
moment I have a movie coming out called
to have and to hold its kind of my first
time really starring in a big-budget
kind of feature e type thing and we're
prepping a new show called sentinels
that we're partnered with Roddenberry
entertainment
Mike co-produces on it mike d sahu who
did Dante's Inferno he did dead space
aftermath is the guy who wrote it and
it's just it's one of the most brilliant
things if not the most brilliant thing
I've ever read and one of our other
partners is Bill McDonald's who created
Rome so it's uh yeah we're pretty
excited about it how cool now I want to
know more about that what's it gonna be
about um it's it's a big huge space
opera and in and when I say opera it i
mean it's it's just so dynamic on so
many levels and i mean it's it's a it's
a hard sci-fi show it's it's back to
being like all the principles of it are
really steep in hard science like stuff
that's not too far in the future and
where I can't say it a lot more than
that but put it this way he's got the
Roddenberry step on it so you know that
it's it's it's gonna be that it's and
we're very excited about it he totes a
little bit about your character in that
I play a real hard-ass um he's
how can I I can't put it this way
there's been something climactic has
happened he's one of the one of the few
survivors of this big event and it's it
changes him it really colors a lot of
who he is this this event and we find
out literally a couple seasons later why
this has all happened and the part that
he's played in it so it's it's not till
you tell ya now what is that coming to a
screen near us we're in prep right now
so it won't be out until 2014 probably
the latter part of 2014 but there will
be an announcement to about what our
network is so any news about the kind of
co-stars you'll have in that um what
there might be some familiar faces not
not from sorry but there there will be
definitely to the sci-fi world there
will be there will be some familiar
faces sunny pretty awesome already I've
already sold on it oh thank you thank ya
we're very excited about it for it's the
end also to film as well well can we get
when we look forward to seeing it um to
happen to hold you know I just did the
ADR so I think the better release date
is I don't like still two months away or
something like that but I'll John
rhys-davies is in it too um who was is
wonderful in by the way but it's a it's
a big epic period piece so that were I'm
excited about that we look forward to
seeing that I look forward to more about
Sentinel to it feels like sweet tooth
expert Thank You Darla I really
appreciate your time thank you very much
you